[Music]
have you ever sat down to take a test
and completely forgotten what you had
studied or
opened your fridge and not remembered
what you came to get
quite often we only remember these
things once we returned to the place
where we studied
or to where we had the initial craving
for that snack
these experiences are so common that
psychologists have studied them for
years
and attribute them to something called
context dependent memory
what is context dependent memory and how
does it work
to understand let's first have a look at
how memories are formed
this usually happens in three stages
encoding storage and retrieval
when you learn something new or have a
new experience
say you meet someone at a party your
brain takes this information
the person's face the sound of their
voice
and transforms it into a memory code a
pattern of activity
in a network of nerve cells this is
known as encoding
the encoded memories are temporarily
stored in short-term memory
and if you call upon them enough they
can get transferred to a more permanent
storage
called long-term memory from where they
can be recalled whenever you need to use
them
this process of accessing information
from long-term memory
is known as retrieval the interesting
thing about forming memories
is that your brain encodes and stores
not only the information that you're
actively focused on
but also some of the contextual
information from your surroundings
things you might overlook like the music
playing in the background
a subtle aroma in the room or the
physical layout of the space
are encoded in addition to your new
friend's face and
name this link between the context and
the thing you want to remember
is the basis for context dependent
memory
when you find yourself struggling to
remember the name of your dance partner
listening to the song that you dance to
or revisiting the location of the party
might help you remember if the context
during retrieval
is similar to the context during
encoding you are
much more likely to recall the memory
the idea of context-dependent memory is
not
only intuitive it has also been
scientifically supported with
experimental data
in one of the classic studies on context
dependent memory
researchers asked two groups of divers
to memorize a list of words in two
different contexts
one group memorized the words while they
were under water
and the other group did this on land
after the words had been memorized
the researchers asked half the divers to
recall the words
in their original learning context and
the other half
to recall the words in the context where
they did not learn the words
the researchers found that words learned
underwater were best recalled underwater
and vice versa other studies have also
shown that internal states and
moods such as feelings of hunger
happiness
or being caffeinated at the time of
memory encoding
can help in the contextualization of
memory
and operate as the retrieval cue
so what affects the strength of a
context-dependent memory
some of the factors that enhance
context-dependent memory at the time of
encoding
are the richness of the context if a
high number of cues
stimulate many different senses the
memory will be better contextualized
the uniqueness of the context save the
high volume of the music playing and
the level of attention you paid the
small details in your surroundings
among factors that interfere with
forming a strong context dependent
memory
are high stress levels or fatigue at the
time of encoding
since these things decrease your
attentiveness to contextual details
now that you know how a specific smell
sound
or feeling can influence the way you
form and recall memories
you can try to use context dependent
memory to your advantage
the next time you're preparing for a
test try studying in a similar
environment to the one you will take
your test in
and if you forget what you wanted from
the fridge try revisiting the place
where you first thought about what snack
you wanted most likely you'll find the
answers that you knew
all along
[Music]
you